?
>> Bret: LUCAS TOMLINSON AT THE
PENTAGON.
LET'S BRING IN RETIRED GENERAL
JACK KEANE.
GENERAL, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS DAY.
>> WELL, IT'S IT'S ASTOUNDING
DAY WHAT'S TAKING PLACE BEFORE
OUR ICE.
AND I THINK FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE MILITARY AND AMERICAN
PEOPLE OUR SOLDIERS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN AFGHANISTAN, IT'S
ALSO A HUMILIATING DAY.
AND VERY FRUSTRATING.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME SERIOUS
MISCALCULATIONS MADE HERE, BRET.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO, THE
PRESIDENT WAS CLAIMING THAT THE
TALIBAN CANNOT TAKE AFGHAN
SECURITY FORCES BE ABLE TO STAND
UP AGAINST IT OBVIOUSLY, WHAT'S
UNFOLDED BEFORE OUR EYES IS
QUITE THE OPPOSITE.
AND THERE ARE REASONABLE
EXPLANATIONS WHY THAT IS THE
CASE.
WHY -- WHY IS THE SITUATION
COLLAPSING SO QUICKLY?
AND ONE OF THE INTANGIBLES THAT
IS SO DIFFICULT TO MEASURE BY
OUR INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY OR
EVEN OUR MILITARY LEADERS IS
THAT WOULD BE THE IMPACT OF
TAKING DECISIVE AIR POWER AWAY
FROM THE AFGHAN SECURITY FORCES
WHO ARE USED TO HAVING U.S. AIR
POWER AND U.S. INTELLIGENCE IN
SUPPORT OF THEM AND THEY HAVE
ALWAYS WITH THAT AIR POWER BEEN
ABLE TO STOP TALIBAN OFFENSES IN
THE PAST IF WE PULL THAT OUT?
WHAT IS THE IMPACT OF THAT?
WELL, THAT'S A SUNGIVE
EVALUATION TO BE SURE.
EVEN THE MILITARY PEOPLE DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT THAT IMPACT WOULD HAVE
ON THE SECURITY FORCES.
AND YOU CAN SEE RIGHT BEFORE OUR
EYES, IT'S NOT THE ONLY REASON
BUT IT'S THE PRIMARY REASON,
THIS IS THE GROUND FORCES USED
TO HAVING VERY CAPABLE U.S. AIR
SUPPORT OFFENSIVE TAKING PLACE
AND THEY DON'T HAVE IT NOW THEY
ARE COMING FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
8 HOURS TO GET THEY CAN'T STAY
THAT LONG.
WHEN YOU ARE DEALING WITH AN
OFFENSIVE YOU HAVE TO BE
ENDURING CONSISTENT AIR POWER
STAYING ON THE TARGET.
CONTINUOUSLY FOR HOURS.
AND THAT MAKES THE ENEMY GO
AWAY.
AND WE NEED GROUND COORDINATORS
TO MAKE THAT.
>> Bret: THIS IS A LONG TIME.
THIS IS ALMOST TWO DECADES ON
THE GROUND AND DID I MANY
STORIES ON IT IN AFGHANISTAN
ABOUT THE AFGHAN TRAINING AND
THE EFFORTS TO GET THAT FORCE UP
AND RUNNING, THE MONEY THAT WAS
SPENT, THE EQUIPMENT THAT WAS
SENT TO THEM.
AND THE AFGHAN FORCES, NUMBER, A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER AND THEY HAVE
GOOD EQUIPMENT.
BUT, YET, WE'RE SAYING THAT THEY
CAN'T DEFEND THEMSELVES.
WE ARE SEEING THESE CITIES FALL
ONE AFTER ANOTHER, HER ROTH,
GAZA ANY, KANDAHAR THIS
AFTERNOON AND MAYBE KABUL THERE
IS SOME THOUGHT MAYBE THEY WON'T
DO THE BIG FIGHT IN KABUL AND
WAIT TO NEGOTIATE.
>> YEAH, CERTAINLY.
I MEAN, AND THAT'S A VALID POINT
TO MAKE.
WE HAVE BEEN THERE 0 YEARS.
WE ARE THERE BECAUSE WE ARE
INVOLVED IN A MULTIGENERATIONAL
WAR AGAINST RADICAL ISLAM THAT
DOESN'T HAVE AN END DATE THAT
I'M AWARE OF.
CERTAINLY NATIONAL LEADER THAT
HAVE DETERMINED THAT AS TO THE
FORCES THEMSELVES, THE AFGHAN
SECURITY FORCES, LISTEN, WE HAVE
ALWAYS HAD PROBLEMS WITH -- WE
HAVE NEVER SAID THAT THIS IS A
HELY CAPABLE FORCE.
THAT I'M AWARE OF.
BUT, NONETHELESS, WE BELIEVE WE
WERE TRAINING TO BE EFFECTIVE
ENOUGH WITH THE ENABLERS
PROVIDED TO THEM TO BE ABLE TO
DEAL WITH THE TALIBAN.
WE KNEW FULL WELL THEY COULDN'T
DEFEAT THE TALIBAN, WE DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH FORCES THERE TO DO
THAT OURSELVES WHEN WE WERE
THERE.
BUT WE NEED FOR A FACT THAT THE
TALIBAN DIDN'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO TAKE THE COUNTRY
OVER EITHER.
AND IT WAS STALEMATED AND THAT'S
WHY PEOPLE WERE SEEKING A
POLITICAL SOLUTION TO WHAT
APPEARED TO BE SOMEWHAT OF AN
ATTRACTABLE PROBLEM FOR BOTH
SIDES THAT THAT WASN'T THE
ANSWER EITHER, OBVIOUSLY.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, GENERAL, YOU
SERVED IN THE VIETNAM WAR.
YOU WERE A RANGER PARATROOPER,
PLATOON LEADER, A COMPANY
COMMANDER, TODAY THAT IMAGE OF
VIETNAM CAME UP IN THE
QUESTIONING OF ADMIRAL JOHN
KIRBY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO AVOID
[INAUDIBLE] WITH THE FALL OF
SAIGON.
>> WHAT'S THIS IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE IS WHAT IT IS.
WE ARE NOT WALKING AWAY FROM OUR
COMMITMENT TO THE AFGHAN FORCES.
WE ARE NOT COMPLETELY
ELIMINATING OUR DIPLOMATIC
PRESENCE ON THE GROUND.
WE ARE STILL GOING TO HAVE
DIPLOMATS THERE.
NOBODY IS ABANDONING
AFGHANISTAN.
NOT WALKING AWAY FROM IT IT'S
DOING THE RIGHT THING AT THE
RIGHT TIME TO PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE.
>> Bret: YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
COMPARISON, THE CONTRAST AND
WHERE WE ARE TODAY?
>> WELL, IT'S ONLY -- IT IS A
REASON FOR COMPARISON,
CERTAINLY.
WE DID LOSE POLITICAL SUPPORT
AND RESOLVE FOR THE WAR IN
VIETNAM WHICH FINALLY THE
CONGRESS TERMINATED ANY
FINANCIAL SUPPORTS WE CAN NO
LONGER PROVIDE AIR POWER TO
SUPPORT THE GROUND FORCES WHICH
WERE THE SOUTH VIETNAMESE AND
WHAT WE ARE SEEING RIGHT BEFORE
OUR EYES TODAY HAPPENED THEN THE
NORTH VIETNAMESE ROLLED UP VERY
QUICKLY.
I WAS JUST -- IT WAS LIKE A GUT
PUNCH FROM PLATOON LEADER
COMPANY COMMANDER TO SEE AN
ENDING LIKE THAT.
I REALLY HELD MY SENIOR MILITARY
LEADERS IN SOMEWHAT IN CONTEMPT
TO BE FRANK ABOUT IT FOR HAVING
THE WRONG STRATEGY FOR THREE
YEARS FROM '65 TO '68 WHICH
PROTRACTED THE WAR AND FROM MY
NATIONAL LEADERS NOT HAVING THE
STOMACH TO STAND UP TO WHAT WAS
TAKING PLACE.
AND HERE WE HAVE MADE SIMILAR
MISCALCULATIONS IN MY MIND.
LISTEN, WE HAVE FIVE PLACES,
BRET, WE HAVE EVOLVED OVER THE
GLOBAL WAR ON TERROR.
WE HAVE GOTTEN MORE
SOPHISTICATED ABOUT IT THERE IS
40 TO 50 MOVEMENTS OUT THERE.
WE ARE ONLY INVOLVED IN FIVE,
SYRIA, IRAQ, YEMEN EAST AFRICA
AND AFGHANISTAN WAS ONE OF THEM.
WHERE U.S. TROOPS ARE INVOLVED
FOR ONE REASON ONLY ALL FIVE OF
THOSE PLACES WE BELIEVE THE
RADICALS THERE HAVE
ASPIRATIONS-TO-ACHE AT THAT TIME
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Bret: I ONLY HAVE A FEW
SECONDS.
>> IT'S A MODEST FORCE FOR ALL
OF THAT SEEMS TO ME TO BE A
PRUDENT DECISION AND HOW YOU ARE
GOING TO SECURE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Bret: JUST A FEW SECONDS.
DO YOU THINK THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WOULD DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT IN EXITING
THIS THAN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE?
>> WELL, I'M NOT EVEN CONVINCED
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD
EVENTUALLY HAVE EXITED EVEN
THOUGH IT OBVIOUSLY WAS PART OF
HIS CAMPAIGN.
I MEAN, I CAN'T DO ANYTHING BUT
SPECULATE ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T KNOW FOR SURE.
LISTEN, I DO KNOW WHEN MADE THE
DECISION TO LEAVE, BRET IT,
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A LOT OF OTHER
ISSUES ON THE TABLE, WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO TO PREVENT THE
TALIBAN FROM TAKING OVER.
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T CONVINCE ME
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS ANY
INTEREST IN THE TALIBAN RUNNING
AFGHANISTAN WITH ALL THE
GEOPOLITICAL SIGNIFICANCE THAT
HAS IN DEALING WITH OUR
ADVERSARIES AND OUR ALLIES,
CERTAINLY.
THAT'S NOT ON HIS AGENDA.
SO WHAT WAS THE IT PROCESS HOW
TOO WE PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING?
BECAUSE 31 AUGUST WOULDN'T EVEN
MAKE SENSE?
HOW ARE WE GOING TO APPORTION
THE RESOURCES?
I DON'T KNOW IF THOSE QUESTIONS
REALLY GOT ANSWERED OR EVEN
ASKED FOR THAT MATTER.
BECAUSE, THIS IS HUGE
MISCALCULATION.
>> Bret: THERE IS NO SENSE THE
TALIBAN WANTS INTERNATIONAL
RECOGNITION FROM THE U.N. OR
ANYBODY ELSE.
GENERAL JACK KEANE, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR ANALYSIS,